I'm having a little bit of a moment
right now when they told me Tiffany was
coming I'm like me Tiffany's coming
great and I was singing your song so on
this morning my kids are listening to
they're like what song this is I'm like
you got to know this song and I'm so
excited that you're on tour right now
New Kids on the Block mixtape tour you
have Naughty by Nature
you've got salt and pepper you got
Debbie Gibson like how did it all happen
who contact you what was the
conversation what happened well I was
actually on tour I've been on tour with
my own project pieces of me my new album
so I've been in the UK touring pounding
the pavement doing a tour here planning
a tour here yeah and then I get the
phone call to be part of the mixtape
tour you know family and tour and I'm
like oh my gosh rearrange everything so
it's been a blast to really be part of
the tour and that I can make it all
happen so I'm kind of popping this in
the middle but you know it's so much fun
to be on the on the road back with New
Kids on the Block its we get a chuckle I
passed them in the hallway and I just
laugh a little bit like you done it what
30 years ago you were on tour and when
you having this conversation now you
must be like this is pretty cool that
we're back together it is really cool I
mean it's great to see Deb and it's I
love the music it's a night of great
music so I'm always dancing back there
getting ready you know it yeah them the
fans are having a blast with it it's a
great time for all of us because a lot
of us have other projects I know Deb's
got some new music I have new music so
it's a great time to celebrate the fans
of 30 years and then let them know
what's going on with us now and it's
starting up for a whole new generation
to know there's so many young young ones
coming to the shows and it's great
because I get to walk through the
audience and I stop especially when
they're young
the little ones they're just an awe at
all you know taking it all in and I'm
like oh you're so cute
and what's seeing them with their Debbie
Gibson shirts or my shirt yeah you know
New Kids on the Block I'm like my shirts
too I should say that I don't know but
it's not have all right
a retro shirt shirt I had to like redo
one of my images and so I tricked it all
out and made it all kind of where it
looks like it's been there for 30 years
you know because yeah I lost all of my
shirts I was a big collector of concert
t-shirts and where they've went I don't
know but I have a suspicion about some
sisters of mine you know I love the fact
that when you were this teen pop
sensation a such a young age you
actually held mucus on the block to
start performing they were part of your
show and a lot of people don't know that
no well they're telling the story now
because anyway
before I do one of my ballads there's on
the screen the big screen and every
night at the shows they tell that that
story they tell the back story about how
they came to my dressing room and
auditioned or really just saying yeah
yeah well they just signed with my
agency and they were just getting their
start and they were gonna look for
obviously ways to tour or be seen and my
agent brought them backstage and my
manager wasn't there that day yeah so
and I had no opening act which was crazy
and boring so you know just music in the
house would be played and then I would
start my show but my manager and I
couldn't you know we couldn't agree on
what would be a great opening act he
wanted a comedian I thought was I good
magician I was like so we were looking
for the perfect at and they walked in
and new kids on the block walked in and
I always took my best friend with me for
the summer so I'd have somebody my own
age and literally it was like haha this
is done what is the problem was that the
selling point for you I mean really they
were sweet and wonderful but I mean no
they came in they auditioned and they
sang and I saw it and it just made sense
I had primarily women out in the
audience
young girls and you know I come from a
country in western background a lot of
people don't know that so you know what
eight nine and ten I was auditioning for
lots of people and it would be like
stand here and yeah yeah you don't have
a guitar you don't have a patent doesn't
matter this is your opportunity and it
really was their willingness to do that
and at that time I said well I
have an opening act tonight if you guys
want to try it you have your tracks just
go out on stage and I heard all these
screams and I was like again all smiles
I thought yeah I've done a good thing
but I got a phone call from my manager
Glenn you never do these things never go
she ate this we don't know what you're
doing but I you know I do think I knew
what I was doing a lot of people and
that makes me happy and one of the great
things at that time was that there you
are with your new album your self-titled
album Tiffany and then Deb you're
talking to Debbie get right out of the
blue and I guess it was the media maybe
it was the people were pitting you guys
against each other you guys got along we
did well we didn't know each other
really yeah you know so all that rivalry
was not true we really didn't know each
other we'd leave little notes here and
there see each other on red carpets yeah
but I mean it was so fast
now we have a friendship yeah which is
great you know and that really happened
when we did our movie mega Python get
annoyed you know saving the world Bond's
people they leave Everglades really need
us very serious stuff Deb and I've been
doing but you know we have always
thought we would bond over music and it
was really during the shooting of the
movie because we had time to sit and
just talk like girls and that's what has
started our conversation about people
putting a year ago we've always chuckled
about that over the years definitely and
you know we've been a little cheeky with
it you know kind of played into it every
- every once in a while especially when
we did the film and the fight scene and
everything we were like yeah we're
getting that rivalry those rivalry
juices going but you know no we're
friends and and it's great because we
understand each other a lot about you
know that time period how it felt you
know how it feels to has grown women to
work on careers now still loving what
we're doing 30 years later being on a
tour together and actually Deb and I
have done shows separately together we
just came back from Singapore and Manila
anything so yeah there's a lot of Debbie
Gibson in my life and there's a lot of
Tiffany and her to be performing
together in this tour no not on this
tour
the mixtape oh you guys can mix it maybe
your honor you can totally get a big
gather and mix those two songs together
it's a lot of fun I mean it really is
this is a great time again to be able to
show in celebrate hmm the retro stuff
and then I just recorded and revamped I
think we're low now new video just said
a million views in a month
amazing yeah and then you know loving
the new version which is just a little
more edgy just a little bit of a rocker
edge to it you know representing what I
am now